ciao ragazzi ben tornati ad una puntata
di cucina buttata siamo ad ottobre tra
una settimana dovrebbe essere halloween
tendenzialmente più o meno è quello che
vorremmo fare è una ricetta a tema
autunno ci sono state tante la zucca è
stata usata in tutti i modi ma non
abbiamo usato in una delle sue
applicazioni forse più divine
molti di voi lo conosceranno altrettanti
di voi lo ammirano sto parlando del
parking spies latte
per chi non lo sapesse il pumpkin spies
latte è una ricetta limitata solamente
per il periodo di ottobre giusto che
dalla regia mi dicono di sé di starbucks
alcuni di voi diranno del starbucks
quello che fai cosi di caffè osceni o
odio il caffè genere nella vita quindi
qualsiasi cosa del caffè dentro tranne
il tiramisù tendenzialmente non mi fa
impazzire ecco perché oggi ho una
sorpresa per voi cercando di mantenere
il più possibile a distanza di sicurezza
vi presento valentina fatti vedere
valentina fra una sfilata per noi
problema è che allora mi hanno detto ma
io mi vesto normalmente così altre
cappella dopo tale 33 anni e non
sentirli
valentina per chi non lo sapesse è una
esperta del punk in space latte ieri ho
visto un suo posto semplice praticamente
volevo un pack in spies latte non
potendo andare a londra era in astinenza
seria e lui mi scrive dicendo ma io
domani ne faccio uno auto invitata
predica miti perché non ricordo il
sapore di spies latte la cosa positiva
che oggi lo scopriremo valentino è come
se avesse assaggiato ieri quando dovesse
essere un successo e qualora voleste
farlo anche a casa vostra pagateci su
instagram doveva farci vedere che cosa
avete creato soprattutto invitatemi
averne uno grazie ha già rotto il cazzo
questo modello anche cucina sei capitato
buttata si guarda io l'ho già fatto la
vita alla persona mi mancava ma possiamo
quindi agli ingredienti per fare il
parking spies latte abbiamo bisogno di
una zucca una tazza mezzo di zucchero
una tazza e mezzo d'acqua sei stecche di
cannella un cucchiaio di chiodi di
garofano ovunque caio di zenzero tritato
2 cucchiai di noce moscata una tazza di
latte un heads di caffè non chiedetemi
cosa sia 1 ott non scopriremo insieme
senza tazza di panna e basta iniziamo
gli americani prendono per scontato che
esista già un posto che comprare in
purea di zucca che io non ho trovato e
allo stesso tempo delle spezie per la
pumpkin pie che andremo a creare quindi
fondamentalmente ho pensato che la cosa
più intelligente da fare fosse prendere
tutti gli ingredienti base e comporre
quelli più difficili a trovare in modo
che tutti quanti potessero crearlo
partiamo subito con la prima cosa il
pure altrimenti ti vuoi un po introdurre
le sta operando una bevanda che fanno
appunto per il periodo di halloween ma
non aveva neanche fosse una bevanda
iniziato a prepararla si vabbè qualcosa
di dolce ma anche molto speziato di
solito la cosa che è stata dichiarata
cannella e chiodi di garofano e poi c'è
questo il chino e rilascia la zucca che
è molto piaciuto non certo di essere
onesto nella notte che tengono in aria
iniziamo subito col perticari tagli
nella zucca evitate di tagliare qua
perché troppo duro invece andategli
attorno quindi con molta pazienza mamma
mia
ok poi dall'altro lato a me taglio dal
vero terrore si no no impossibile è un
disastro ma non si sa ancora amputato
niente ma ecco mi raccomando ragazzi
fate attenzione perché dura se riuscite
trovate le zucche quelli più piccoline
arancioni che sono belle e dolci io
trovo purtroppo solamente questa ma
comunque mi ritengo soddisfatto guardate
che succede la magia adesso pornografico
step 2 con la zucca
poi silenzio si si possono fare il forno
se volesse andiamo a scavare col
cucchiaio eliminare completamente tutti
quanti i semi come dice valentina sono
bellissimi secchi quindi il quadrato e
stessi carli invitate valentina a cena
da voi anche così evitiamo di averla noi
in mezzo e colleoni
hai mangiato i semi di zucca no no non
li ho mai mangiato ok
un aggettivo per definire la zucca al
forno magica ma vai a cagare
davvero un bel termine musical magica
zucca ore che aperte prendete la zucca
faccia in giù sulla teglia del forno
infine infiliamo dentro al forno e
ragazze e proprio collassare su se
stessa partita sembra poter ricevere
vorrei diciamo che ci stiamo lavorando
andiamo avanti prepariamo il topping di
spezie in modo da avvantaggiare cielo
nel frattempo vale se vuoi fare uno
spuntino questo è per te avremmo bisogno
di un cucchiaino da terna
purtroppo non ho comprato la cannella in
polvere l'ho presa solamente in stecche
e quindi ora devo riuscire ad averla in
polvere secondo me è meglio così ti
metti sul tagliere l'esperto scusami con
di doppiare turi di una vera e stenta e
lo dico io ti rispetta prosperoso sto
parlando di valentino anche tutta bella
accollata facci fare subito
visualizzazioni alla fine un cucchiaino
scarso di cannella da vedere perché tu
stai lavorando nell'ombra il maniero
scusi non sarà un vero pumpkin spies
perché io posso dire una cosa valentina
quella porta si sente il campo per
prenderla un cucchiaino di cannella
macinata un quarto di cucchiaino di noce
moscata macinato per non esser messe una
rompico revised un quarto di cucchiaino
di zenzero e un ottavo di chiodi di
garofano macinati inneschi un momento di
approfondimento con il nostro naso
allora tutto molto buono ci fosse un po
più di cannella dove manca un po di
cannella stata sticazzi andiamo avanti
mancano gli ultimi 11 minuti li tiriamo
fuori
non riesce a raccontarla in 40 secondi
ci provi allora fuori da questo canale
allora vai una storia di terrore in cui
tu sei coinvolto il suo mimmo dietro il
gioco di ruolo dal vivo quindi stavo
facendo questo evento a tema stringer
thing visto che dovevo fare una seduta
spiritica in gioco guglielmo e offre di
darmi la sua dicendo io te la regalo
basta che tu non la faccia mai più
rientrare in questa casa quindi mi
faccio dare questa vola luisa e vado
all'evento questa seduta spiritica avevo
letto che bisogna chiedere il nome allo
spirito perché sennò si arrabbiano non
volevo creare un nome reale quindi ho
detto butto lettere a caso è l'unica che
scelgo è stata la g in onore di
guglielmo esce questa parola mai sentita
prima blues cup e pensa ammazza potete
impegnarvi un pochino di più credo che
invece uno dei ragazzi in gioco mi legge
fa storia dicendo sì certo brusca per
adulterio habana chi continua a parlare
di questo blues cup finita la seduta
spiritica io gli dico guarda che l'ho
inventato a caso questo nome e lui mi
dice hai inventato questo e mi fa vedere
la pagina wikipedia di gus cup che ho
iniziato a piangere me ne volevo andare
con tutte le mie forze
credo che sia la cosa più spaventosa che
mi sia mai successa in vita mia ragazzi
e questo è motivo per cui non dovreste
mai farvi regalare da greta menchi delle
tavolette guisa che poi vi rimangono a
casa era venuta cretamente dice faccio
con questa tavoletta cui se non la
volevo fare la per un solo video in
realtà molto divertente il frate alla
fine abbiamo fatto più niente e mi ha
fatto promettere lascio aiuto del
terrore di qualcosa non avrà lasciato
beretta in casa tra parentesi minuti
mando un bacio la pena è arrivata lei
bisogno ma prendi la rendita è tua e
tanta mi lavai che giocheremo tutti
insieme al vice ogni cosa ha un prezzo
no è la mia anima c'è un po più alto di
80.000 like ok pur 600.000 teniamo cosa
è successo in questo momento là dentro
c'è il male prendiamo la zucca
incominciamo proprio facilmente a
rimuovere la polpa dalla pelle che poi
senti già dall'odore quanto è dolce come
sempre per attaccare minipimer avremo
di un momento di buio ha visto che siamo
in modalità halloween questa cosa
funziona questo qui è il risultato che
ho ottenuto naturalmente lo metterò da
parte visto che non mi si avvera tutto
quanto ci farò altra roba buonissima
tipo la mia pasta alla zucca che far
assaggiare a valentina detto ciò andiamo
con lo sciroppo che è il vero
protagonista della ricetta è il vero
ingrediente segreto della ricetta quindi
andiamo a fare il suo sciroppo una tazza
e mezzo di zucchero
porca miseria una tazza e mezzo d'acqua
e accendiamo il fuoco
signore e signori questo questo ha pian
piano sembra venga che vuol dire sbolli
qiando sembra ogni volta ci sono acqua
zucchero insieme zucchero anzi scusate
insieme io mi sento male questo è
semplificare ricci care fisica e se deve
venire uno sciroppo dire che dopo poi
aggiungo tutto il resto è lo devo fare
andare avanti per una ventina di minuti
come dicono loro finché quindi non andrà
un pochino a restringersi deve essere un
po vischiosi liquido liquido aspettiamo
a buonissimo l'anatema ci ha lanciato
abbiamo aggiunto cannella senza era noce
moscata e chiodi di garofano finiamo con
4 cucchiai di questo pure 1234 c'è
quattrini di cure si e tu hai fatto una
zuppiera norma non si tiene ben di merda
non supererà i jukka e facciamo andare
adesso per 20 minuti è un po ma persone
non bellissimo da vedere
no non essere così duro ragazzi siamo
arrivati a questo mostriamo 21 20 minuti
che cos'è che sia ministro ring metering
sarebbe sempre le insegne spegniamo il
fuoco e finché ancora caldo lo andiamo a
scolare incredibile li levin coi bastoni
cioè per fare sereno gianni e sciropposo
e calcolate che adesso è caldissimo ti
ricorda qualche
sì sì sì è perfetto è perfetto ma è che
mentre aspettiamo che si raffreddi
passiamo al latte panna e caffè
consistenza perfetta come picchia di
spezie secondo me è il sapore giusto del
pakistan
andiamo a passare agli ultimi passaggi
io il caffè non lo so fare qui ora io mi
perdo la domanda è il cartello ha
schiacciato possa fare uso va fatta la
montagnetta barba con la forchetta
bucherellato un pò chi dà e poi chiude
una montagnetta chiudo facciamo il fuoco
basso a questo punto mentre ma il caffè
nel frattempo montiamo lava e un casino
nero sono in riunione infatti sono uno
sconto tolgo la luce come sempre
wow latte veloci riscaldiamo lo
purtroppo non ho pentolini fiscali o
questo per montare il latte non
chiedetemi perché ce l'abbia perché io
credo di aver mai montato il latte in
mai usato questo coso ma sono quegli
acquisti compulsivi che a un certo punto
nella tua vita ti tornano utile che o
c'è quel giorno lo sentite e l'odore del
traguardo
stiamo arrivando alla fine è successo
davvero
prepariamoci alla direttiva assieme tra
la devastazione totale a questo latte
sembra caldo e basta ok il latte sa qua
dentro piazziamo sopra questo coperchio
troppo la qui veramente felice di
vedervi questo cappuccino non li falsi
così l'ha buttata via
ok ragazzi sono 100 il caffè non ci
credo io sono due cucchiai noi abbiamo
tutti gli ingredienti abbiamo uno
sciroppo abbiamo il latte abbiamo il
caffè e abbiamo la panna abbiamo anche
le nostre spezie per il topping di sopra
le ho buttate ma non sono buonissime
secondo me ne faremo a meno andiamo
avanti
prima di assaggiare non bisogna mai
parlare 3 cucchiai di sciroppo 23 2
cucchiai di caffè 1 dura una tazza di
latte un altro bello mescoliamo a questo
punto aggiungiamo la panna e le spezie
signori questo il nostro pumpkin spies
l'attendiamo all'assaggio allora li ho
visti di migliori cioè la pazza è molto
carina ma non l'hai fatta tu
bisogna dire una cosa era l'attentato
abbiamo dovuto aspettare un pochino 15
st che sia diventato una palude ma è
normale che sia diventato giallo ma i
vostri non erano così aspetto gli do 5
state le spezie soprano avrebbe avuto un
valore aggiunto aspetto visto la
reference e non ci siamo per niente
quattro e mezzo l'affetto non è
invitante darei
poi c'è questa cosa qui gialla che la
zucca che mi sembra tipo mia stanza ma è
orribile 4 abbassa il mio voto
sessantenni che bono si sente tutto il
caffè sa di caffè quindi 46 e mezzo
perché il caffè mi piace comunque non mi
piace cioè cinque e mezzo mi sento delle
spezie quindi quattro e mezzo non è così
terribile 5 e mezzo se non dici ma dove
la faccia
allora forse è un po troppo dolce del
punk e spies a un pochino più speziato e
meno dolce ci siamo anche buono più
natalizio che autunnale devo dire che il
sapore forse è una delle cose migliori
cioè non è vomitevole pensavo fosse
terrificante e tra l'altro visto che
l'unica cosa che potrà assaggiare che
gli assomigliano benissimo ti dà idea di
stare su un divano con una coperta
addosso e fuori piove e mezzo sette e
mezzo 6 meno quanto stessi di spostato a
creare qualcosa che assomigli a un punk
in spite latte pure 10 euro per i top
tutti però poi mi regali calderone me lo
porto
se mi dai anche il divano la coperta è
la casa 800 euro al mese da insieme la
offrono l'assaggio volentieri su un
divano con la coperta
io non lo comprerei mai e poi mai sarei
disposto a pagare niente perché non me
la comprerei mai magari siamo arrivati
alla fine di questo video mi raccomando
se farete anche voi il papi pumpkin
spies la creation e siamo arrivati alla
fine di questo video se perde anche voi
il punk e fight club e mi raccomando
taggate mi nelle nostre storie su
instagram ma soprattutto iscrivetevi a
questo canale attivate la campagna delle
notifiche metteteci un pollice in su per
il sono solo per l'impegno e fateci
sapere qua sotto soprattutto se siete
riusciti ad arrivare alla fine di questo
video e grazie vale adesso è stato
nostro ospite
un bacione grande ci vediamo giovedì
alle 12 con un altro video
ciao